As we go to our next game
Point of No Return.
Life is a journey full
of wondrous milestones,
like a baby's first steps,
a child's first kiss,
jacking off to the DVD box
of your mom's workout video,
hearing the garage door open,
and desperately wiping off
the DVD before she gets back
from the grocery store
and crying 'cause you don't know
what's happening to your body,
and then
eventually getting married
and having a family of your own.
So, while universal experiences
like those come
at different times
for different people,
Thrillist has compiled a list
of things we should stop doing
at certain ages.
Like age three,
stop sucking your thumb.
All right.
Age 25, stop working for free.
Age 33, stop crying at work.
But...
-I'm sure some...
-33?
33. 33's the cutoff.
-They give you a long time...
-Seems pretty far, yeah.
-Yes. -That's a long time
to stop crying.
It's 35 in New Jersey.
I'm sure some
were left off the list,
so I'd like you to give me
some other things
you should have gotten over
by a certain age in 60 seconds.
-And begin. Randazzo.
-(bell dings)
Age 20,
stop marrying Hugh Hefner.
-Points. Hodgman.
-(bell dings)
Age 49, stop kidding yourself
that you're anything but meat.
-Points. Paul F.
-(bell dings)
Age 25, stop reading
Charles Bukowski.
-Points. Paul F. Tompkins.
-(bell dings)
Age 18, stop being dead
for three years. Dogs only.
Points.
-(bell dings)
-Randazzo.
Age 27, stop telling everyone
you're an atheist.
We (bleep) know.
-All right, points. Paul F.
-(bell dings)
Age 45, being relevant.
All right, points.
-(bell dings)
-Randazzo.
Age seven, stop wetting the bed.
-Points. Randazzo.
-(bell dings)
Age 67,
start wetting the bed again.
-Points. Randazzo!
-(bell dings)
Oh! Age 81,
stop referring to the Irish as
dirty potato (bleep), Grandpa.
Points.
-(bell dings)
-Hodgman.
Age 1,037, stop drinking
the blood of orphans
to replenish
your wretched life force.
(buzzer sounds)